bonsoir jean claude mailly le secrétaire
général de force ouvrière est l'invité
de preuves par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous pour répondre
comme chaque semaine dans cette émission
à trois grandes questions jean claude
mailly d'abord est ce que vous êtes
choqué par la rémunération du patron de
psa qui a doublé l'an dernier
ensuite croyez vous encore possible de
faire barrage à la loi travail dont le
parcours parlementaire commence en ce
moment même avec myriam el khomri vous
le dirai à marcq réelle de l'agencé
france presse le partenaire de public
sénat pour ce rendez-vous de preuve par
trois enfin troisième question
redoutez-vous la rupture du modèle
social en cas de victoire de la droite
en 2017 ce serait la conséquence pour
manuel valls vous répondrais là un
mickaël szames s alors première question
donc carlos tavares le président de
peugeot citroën créé la polémique avec
sa rémunération qui a doublé l'an
dernier pour se hisser à 5 millions deux
cent quarante mille euros est ce que
vous êtes choqués voire plus
écoutez c'est évident que le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que ça surprend
une telle augmentation que c'est sur
dimensionné notamment par rapport aux
négociations salariales qui viennent
d'avoir lieu dans le groupe psa je
rappelle que l'accord s'est fait à 1,25
pour cent donc on est loin tel écart
donc c'est vrai que ces dunes
une augmentation qui choque ça c'est
évident ceci étant regardons aussi la
manière dont les choses se font quand je
dis la manière dont les choses se font
ça veut dire que c'est le mode de
rémunération des présidents de ces
entreprises qui est en cause celle là où
d'autres au niveau international quand
les présidents sont non seulement des
salaires fixes importants mais également
intéressé au rendement financier des
actions vis-à-vis des dividendes quand
on arrive à ce type de situation dans
l'automobile ses oreilles bah oui où
plus aucune plus cartonné avec u2 ou
chez daimler et c est le mode de
rémunération c'est le mode de fûts de
financement et de rémunération qui pose
problème est là le mode de rémunération
il est avec ses sur la réussite de nuit
une rampe patron or il a tassé inter
l'ancien avant ton bon compte avait-il
prévu à l'avancé avant son prédécesseur
avait fait un gros travail je vous
rappelle philippe varin avait fait un
travail important qui étaient poursuivis
a eu un autre plan qui a été lancé par
monsieur tavares ensuite dans la foulée
c'est vrai que le groupe à de meilleurs
résultats je vous rappelle aussi que
nous avons signés force ouvrière et
d'autres organisations
un accord pour aider l'entreprise à un
moment donné on n'a pas accepté de
baisse de salaire des mobilités forcées
mais il ya eu des efforts de réaliser
par les salariés ce qui est normal
puisque l'entreprise à l'ena en fait
j'écoute vous ne jetez pas du tout la
pierre ainsi sur un individu quel qu'il
soit il ya un problème de rémunération
de l'ensemble des présidents de ces
sociétés quelle qu'elle soit ceux des
multinationales et satan qu'on aurait dû
le rapace problème ben y en aura sept
ans par exemple 5 millions d'euros pour
moi c'est un problème battant des bacs
et enfin il a pas beaucoup qui gagnent
ça non mais c'est évident mais est ce
que c'est important mais on se rend même
pas compte pas ces problèmes ce mode de
rémunération d'une manière générale sont
disproportionnées mais pour tous les
présidents de multinationales alors soit
parmi les actionnaires de psa il y à
l'état un état qui a d'ailleurs approuvé
les mesures qui entrent en vigueur
aujourd'hui au bénéfice de monsieur
carlos tavares mais l'état et qu'ils
aient eu à voter également contre cette
rémunération
mais est ce que l'état ne montre pas
surtout en ce moment son impuissance est
ce que vous le regrettez il ya une
participation dans le capital elle était
en état n'est pas majoritaire c'est un p
ca c'etait il était intervenu dans le
capital comme d'autres intervenants il
sait rien et l'entreprise sauvée pour
sauver l'entreprise donc l'entreprise
est reparti 1 avec des efforts qui ont
été faits par les salariés je le redis
comme chez renault c'est la même chose à
l'entreprise est reparti et également et
la construction automobile se porte pas
trop mal
pas trop mal en ce moment bien alors je
vous propose d'écouter ce qu'en dit le
président du medef pierre gattaz qui lui
justifie cette rémunération là à cette
hauteur là on les côtés vous réagissez
tous salué félicité carlos tavares du
redressement exceptionnelle qui l'a fait
de de psa vous savez cette société fait
quand même 150 mille personnes 55
milliards de chiffre d'affaires est en
grande difficulté et quelques années
souvenez vous
est obligé de s'adosser à un actionnaire
chinois faisait des pertes 5 milliards
de perte il à redresser cette société
qui est en perdition calé sur les
rochers c'est un cargo et bravo
remarquable il faut savoir que cette
rémunération élimination de la réussite
et en effet il faut savoir récompenser
la réussite alors sans revenir forcément
sur le montant de la rémunération
jean-claude manesse que vous avez envie
de dire bravo aussi pour avoir redressé
l'entreprise quels que soient les
talents à l'individu c'est pas le seul
président qui réussit à redresser
l'entreprise mais comme tout le monde
c'est tout le monde s'y est mis
oui voilà ce qu'il a fait jusqu'à
présent il a fait son boulot de
président il a participé il ya la
direction d'entreprise via les salariés
il ya les syndicats compris leur
responsabilité dans cette affaire c'est
pas lui tout seul qui adresse une
entreprise ce serait trop facile d'une
manière ou d'une autre bon alors pierre
gattaz oui bah il justifie tout lui il
faut un rappel qu'il est président du
patronat de gagner autant de titres qui
les gagnent d'ailleurs j'en sais rien
peut-être pas mais en tous les cas est
ce que pour vous carlos tavares est un
bon patron c'est un patron qui pour le
moment tous les cas n'a pas licencié
on a une entreprise qui fonctionne à
bord la con que ça veut dire quoi mon
patron c'est que vous menez des
appareils pour le moment où un bilan ben
oui mais attendez un bilan c'est pas
c'est pas l'homme providentiel non plus
je dis bien l'entreprise avait commencé
son redressement avant et il ya eu des
réformes de structure avec la famille
avec l'intervention de l'état des
interventions extérieures donc il est
dans une logique de développement de
l'entreprise matin ça justifie pas
maintenant que n'importe qu'elle
rémunère s'il ya sans doute quelqu'un
que vous respectez qui s'appelle louis
gallois inquiète le président du conseil
de surveillance de psa est d'ailleurs
une fonction qu'il occupe à titre
bénévole c'est gratuit pour lui et qui
juge la rémunération donc du président
non disproportionnée quand il l'a
comparé comme vous d'ailleurs à celle
versée à quelques à tous les patrons du
cac 40 en fait oui mais j'évite de
regarder c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est le problème c'est le mode
de rémunération de ses patrons
puisqu'ils sont intéressés d'une
certaine manière au résultat y compris
financiers d'entreprises donc plus vous
avez de résultats financiers plus vous
servez de dividendes mieux vous êtes
rémunéré dans quelle logique financière
qui est un moment de rire isolant port
vous aviez carlos tavares en face de
vous là qu'est ce que vous lui diriez
serait de faire d'avoir mis le même
proportion en augmentation à plus fort
que les à 25 pour les salines d'accord
alors pour les salariés ça a été annoncé
par lui même il y aurait une prime de
2000 euros prime de 2000 euros grâce à
ses bons résultats et puis également 400
euros qui seront versés puisque peugeot
citroën a totalement chamboulé un comme
vous le réclamiez evo parmi d'autres
syndicats le système des retraites
chapeau donc il ya quand même des
listings et qui vont dans le bon sens en
chine qui vont il ya des signes qui vont
dans le bon sens je rappelle que force
ouvrière est la première organisation
dans groupe est ce que vous craignez que
cette nouvelle polémique n'aurait sans
doute d'autres puisque les entreprises
commencent à publier leurs résultats
affaiblissent encore la cohésion sociale
dans notre pays ce sont toujours des
exemples quand vous êtes au smic ou des
deux salariés c'est des sommes qui
paraissent astronomiques pour tout le
monde donc un risque
abbas est un risque d'inégalité face à
montre les inégalités dans notre société
en france comme ailleurs dans tous les
pays industrialisés aujourd'hui les
inégalités n'ont jamais été aussi
importantes qu'en ce moment 1 depuis la
financiarisation de l'économie notamment
et une logique libérale
les lits les inégalités se sont accrues
très fortement dans tous les pays y
compris chez donc avec des conséquences
pour la cohésion s'il a droit également
dans les urnes
il ya deux manières de régler aussi
c'est pas forcément de limiter les
rémunérations mais c'est par l'aspect
fiscal
on peut très bien fiscalement sur des
rémunérations de ce type chargé bon
c'est déjà un peu le cas vous le savez
mais vous aimeriez qu'il ya une toise
pour les plus hautes rémunérations
s'était paré dirigeants forme ça fait
partie d'une réforme fiscale on va vous
dire qu'on va nous dire que c'est
interdit que c'est une porte bien c'est
à côté
la toise peut se faire par la fiscalité
c'est là qu'on peut le faire et ce à un
état a la possibilité de faire une
réforme fiscale et de rétro dire plus de
justice fiscale notamment dans l'impôt
sur le revenu en tous les cas je note
que parmi nos déclarations là depuis le
début de sa mission
vous dites que vous faites pas opposée
comme syndicaliste au doublement du
salaire en clair et objectif atteint
pour tous les salariés jeudi pour tout
le monde pour tout le monde vous êtes
d'accord tout le monde on est d'accord
d'accord mais pas forcément pour les
plus hauts talons
ces chauffeurs mentionné c'est très
surdimensionné alors c'est peut-être
trop facile de passer à la question de
la rémunération des fonctionnaires après
ce qu on aime dire l instant
le gouvernement a donc annoncé une
hausse de 1,2 pour cent ou trouver
l'argent selon vous coûter l'argent
quand et dans quelle situation
aujourd'hui les très mauvaises vous le
savez oui elle est très beau il ya des
améliorations du côté de l'uefa les
améliorations du côté de bercy je
demande à voir
ouais hein parce que la diminution du
déficit c'est aussi dû au fait qu'il ya
moins d'investissements notamment du
côté des collectivités territoriales
donc c'est pas forcément une bonne
nouvelle parce que qui dit moins
d'investissements dits des problèmes de
croissance dit les problèmes du des
problèmes d'activité
alors bon écoutez la rumination qu'on
considère insuffisant je rappelle que le
calcul fait par les fonctionnaires fo et
d'autres organisations c'est dire la
perte de pouvoir d'achat est la hauteur
de 2 8%
maintenant complètement contestées vous
le savez par le gouvernement par la cour
des comptes qui de son côté de leurs
achats sur le point d'indicé revoir la
règle générale la wii no matter
fonctionnaires le point d'indicé un pc
wii no ma quand vous tenez compte de
l'ancienneté quand vous tenez compte des
promotions etc
c'est la lecture c'est toute la
différence entre une négociation en
masse une négociation en niveau 1 c'est
toute la différence
nous on a toujours syndicalement défendu
les négociations niveau quand les
employeurs y compris l'état n'est
négocié en masse il regarde sur l'aspect
comptable et budgétaire à ces deux
visions différentes de la négociation
alors où l'état peut-il trouver selon un
message les deux milliards par
différents - annuel de cette hausse du
point d'indicé d'abord cela me faisait
d'abord s'il faisait une politique
économique différente qui à mener plus
d'activités plus de croissance plus
d'investissements et qu'on soit moins
dans une logique de serrer les boulons
comme on le fait depuis des années il y
aurait des marges des marges de
manoeuvre ensuite comme je lé indiqué
plusieurs fois on feu il faut aussi
revoir le si par exemple système des
aides publiques aux entreprises un vous
savoir que sur trois ans est le
fondement même de la politique
économique est suivie actuellement oui
c'est pour ça qu'ils se plantent parce
que les résultats c'est quand même pas
terrible les résultats de la politique
économique
une bonne partie des résultats le
chômage progresse par le petit bout de
croissance qu'on a
un deux ou qu'on aura cette année il est
essentiellement due à des éléments
extérieurs plus qu'à des éléments
puisque à des éléments intérieurs lui
dire la baisse de l'euro l'euro c'est
plus ça qui génère de la croissance
qu'autre chose
bon mais je rappellerai que alors vos
trois ans qu'une réorientation des aides
c'est un des éléments sur trois ans
cumule le cicr plus le pack de
responsabilités ça fait 100 milliards
d'euros me rappeler du clint le monsieur
gattaz 100 milliards d'euros à millions
les 100 milliards ils vont les avoir sur
trois ans cumulés le pin s'il ne met
plus un d'ailleurs parce que les
millions d'enfants ne l'a jamais vu
bailat il est comme son père quand il
avait promis à 25 ans 400 soit 400
millions pour les a jamais vu non plus
donc c'est pas qu'il y ait des aides aux
entreprises on conteste pas vous voulez
mais contrepartie réelle en termes oui
mais ça veut dire qu'il faut que ce soit
en emploi ou d'investissement ce soit
des aides ciblées
ça fait une espèce de contrat entre
l'aide publique et l or est le résultat
de l'entreprise
ça existe dans certaines régions des
régions le fond by paul les uns
pourraient s'en inspirer plutôt que l à
lagos les jeunes demandent donc au
premier ministre a mais seul pour la
première fois à réduire bon c'est la
république est le premier haut il faut
cibler évaluer sérieusement toutes les
aides publiques et les re ciblé par
quand vous avez des multinationales
parler de rémunération tout à l'heure
des plaisirs mais quand vous avez des
multinationales qui réalisent 5,6
milliards d'euros de bénéfices croyez
qu'elles soient utiles qu'elles
perçoivent 170 soit 180 millions type
d'une cice je pense pas moi c'est pour
être utile à autre chose alors à propos
des aides que le gouvernement multiplie
ces derniers temps on va pas parler bien
sûr
d'une aide pour les fonctionnaires avec
le relèvement de voir une alice mais
enfin il ya les plans de sauvetage de
l'agriculture il ya la garantie jeunes
et serieys le plan formation à chaque
fois le gouvernement dit toutes ces
dépenses nouvelles vont être engagées
compensées par des économies est ce que
c'est une règle qui vous convient non
non c'est pas une règle qui convient
parce que qui dit économie on voulait
prendre ou les économies si c'est dans
les emplois d'une manière générale dans
la photo de lui qui se voyait déjà
beaucoup d'endroits où il ya des
problèmes que ce soit finances que ce
soit dans les douanes que ce soit dans
l'inspection du travail dans les
hôpitaux etc
donc on va les prendre où on va à
nouveau réduire les dépenses
d'investissements publics
je rappelle que les collectivités
territoriales c'est 70% de
l'investissement public il ya déjà des
chutes dans les investissements avec un
impact sur l'emploi dans le secteur
privé donc de dire on va faire de
dépenses nouvelles parfois pour des
motifs plus ou moins électro on sent
qu'il ya des élections qui arrivent
année prochaine et en même temps dire on
va réduire ailleurs j'attends de voir où
mes la réduction des dépenses publiques
et sociales c'est une erreur de fond
puisque ça au-delà de ça crée des
inégalités
en plus ça plombe la croissance alors
vous vous contestez donc les
améliorations des finances publiques en
matière de dette et de déficit c'est
vrai qu'on reste néanmoins à un niveau
record particulièrement en europe
ça c'est un point je vois remarquer
d'ailleurs on parle on ne parle toujours
que du déficit budgétaire les fameux 3 %
et on ne parle très peu de la dette
publique qui elle continue explosé et
notamment depuis 2008 depuis la crise
parce qu'on a transféré de la dette
privée vers de la dette publique ce qui
fait que si demain ce que personne ne
doute ne peut souhaiter une nouvelle
crise financière qui paiera on pourra
plus transférer sur la dette publique
alors même si vous contestez donc ces
améliorations qui se revendiquait par
bercy certains à gauche notamment évoque
l'existence d'une mini cagnotte
quel est votre point de vue là dessus
donc c'est parce que on avait dit ce
serait 3,8 ou trois sets et 63,5 ouais
je crois que c'est peanuts
si vous voulez pas dit c'est pas ça le
problème problème ça vous de envie de
roulement des merlus je veux dire la
ligue l'idée que la gauche à un via une
mini cagnotte de 6 milliards d'euros qui
est aberrant d'en parler mais revoir
l'orientation de la politique économique
c'est ça que nous réclamons depuis
longtemps alors autre question sur le
prélèvement à la source est en chantier
à bercy vous le savez vous vous êtes
pour vous non on n'était pas pour qu'on
n'était pas pour on comprenait pas
l'utilité
faire ce prélèvement à la source
pourquoi parce que vous avez près de 70
% des ménages qui sont mensualisées
aujourd'hui donc pourquoi pour 30%
restants d'une certaine manière versa
bon on à horna on a rencontré monsieur
sapin et monsieur les caire la semaine
dernière bon il nous donne des garanties
par exemple sur le fait que l'employeur
n'aura pas connaissance de la situation
familiale parce qu'on va continuer parce
qu'il ya les assurances ont été apportés
leur employeur ne connaîtra que le taux
d'imposition
oui qui peut varier selon les ménages et
ces termes ne rassure pas totalement le
problème c'est après tout n'est pas
réglé comment on fait pour les salariés
multi-employeurs sait pas trop comment
comment on fait pour ceux qui ont des
services à domicile personnes avec les
césures les champs comme un service
c'est pas réglé non plus comment on fait
pour les indépendants pour faire aussi
du prélèvement direct à la source sur
quelles bases et c'est parce que si on
traite différemment les uns et les
autres il ya risque
d'inconstitutionnalité donc y compris
techniquement c'est pas gagné 1 il ya
encore beaucoup de choses beaucoup de
choses à faire et on n'a pas abordé
volontairement avec le ministre le côté
travail des fonctionnaires des finances
il abordera sa avec le fédération de
fonctionnaires mais c'est un des aspects
également donc tout n'est pas réglé dans
l'accord est ce que pour vous cette
réforme va faire attention aussi que
2017 soit peu utilisé par certains je
pense poseriez là puisque comme il n'y
aura pas d'impôts directs sur 2017 pour
faire une opération d'optimisation
fiscale
bien sûr là paraît-il que bercy
réfléchit à cela aurait d'ailleurs vite
instauré des garde-fous pour ceux qui
voudraient en profiter les petits malins
mais est ce que cette ce prélèvement à
la source et le prélever le prélude
selon vous une réforme d'envergure qui
verrait la fusion de l'impôt sur le
revenu et de la csg 1 qui frappe les
salaires et qui deviendrait progressive
est ce que ça c'est un sujet
d'inquiétude pour vous oui c'est un
sujet d'inquiétude parce que l'on
considère que ça peut être une première
étape pour le moment michel sapin nous
dit on n'est pas question on est contre
bon ok mais ça peut être une première
étape et nous on est content cette
fusion est une idée qui a cours à gori
revient sur wii mais l' avantage de la
csg qui est un impôt l'avantagent de la
scène j'ai c'est que c'est un impôt
fléché ça va vers la protection sociale
cissé fusionner dans un autre impôt je
m'inquiète pour le financement de la
protection sont là ou si vous avez des
craintes tout à fait bien enfin la
première partie de cette émission jean
claude mailly on va parler maintenant
de la réforme du droit du travail que le
gouvernement veut donc mener à bien un
texte de compromis diversement appréciée
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire après
les concessions qui ont été faites à
certains syndicats il ya quelques
semaines avant d'accueillir marc réel de
l' agence france-presse
qui vous demandera donc si vous croyez
encore possible de faire barrage à cette
loi elle connerie a bien écoute la
ministre qui était devant les députés il
ya quelques instants
mais je résumerais la philosophie du
texte avec l'équation suivante aucune
souplesse ne sera possible sans
négociation et puisque les entreprises
ont besoin de souplesse la négociation
débouchera sur des accords équitables
ces accords devront recueillir
l'assentiment des organisations
représentant la majorité des salariés ce
qui est une grande avancée si elle
suscite même si elle suscite parfois des
craintes de blocage
bonsoir m'appelle donc votre question
sur cette loi âprement débattus
peut-être commencer par aurait pour
rebondir sur ce que dit la ministre ali
finalement avec cette loi on renforce la
négociation est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui vous parle non ça me parle pas
au sens où c'est faux c'est tout
simplement faux mais j'ai essayé
d'expliquer maintes et maintes fois
madame aime conneries ce qu'était la
hiérarchie des normes
visiblement ça rende pas où je me suis
mal expliqué où elle a pas compris
il faut bien comprendre que quand c'est
la philosophie générale du texte c'est
ce que nous contestons c'est un des
points que nous contestons on est en
train de glisser d'un système que je
qualifie mois républicains ont sens on
assure un minimum d'égalité de droits
par des négociations de branche au
niveau national vers un système on donne
la priorité à l'entreprise comme niveau
négociations résultats de ça et je
l'expliquais dix fois vingt fois mais
bon il ya pas pire sourd que celui qui
ne veut pas entendre les pays qui ont
fait ça
l'espagne par exemple quatre ans après
qu'est ce qu'on constate de 12 millions
de salariés couverts par des conventions
collectives on est passé à 7 millions
prenez le portugal c'est la même chose
vous prenez l'allemagne
on est descendu à 60 % de couverture
conventionnelle c'est une logique qui
est une logique libérale au sens et que
nous aller encore plus loin en disant
c'est une logique anti républicaine ah
bah oui parce que la république liberté
égalité fraternité ca / amy
égalité c'est quoi l'égalité
républicaine s'est assuré un minimum
d'égalité de droits un minimum c'est pas
l'égalitarisme
comment on assure ça en terme de travail
on assure sa part des conventions
collectives nationales dans la
métallurgie la chimie la banque
vous avez des règles qui s'appliquent
dans l'ensemble du secteur après on peut
négocier dans l'entreprise là sur toute
une série de points en matière de durée
du travail la branche saute on passe
directement l'entreprise
prenez les heures supplémentaires demain
dans une entreprise on pourra dire baal
est sous pression de l'employeur parce
qu'il y aura un problème on paiera les
heures sup les premières à 10% et
l'autre côté dire ah bah non moi ce sera
12 et après ce sera 15
donc on va accroître les inégalités
c'est déstructurant c'est la france est
le premier pays au monde en termes de
couverture conventionnelle à grâce à
notre système le gouvernement quand même
déjà pas mal reculé
la cfdt finalement soutien total à l'été
ce sont ce qu'on appelle des coucous
savez ce que c'est les coucous ça ceux
qui vont raconter new bike coucou c'est
ce qu'ils vont dans le nid des autres
pour pondre leurs oeufs et les bons
alors s'il ya eu un incident et
syndicales là c'est la guerre oui parce
que moi quand on m'attaque je réponds
aux abords c'est pas ça mais je sais ce
que je veux dire par là il ya eu
quelques petits reculs pour le moment
mais la philosophie générale n'a pas
changé et est encore toute une série de
points très lourds très importants qui
sont condamnables et qui constituent des
régressions sociales c'est pour ça que
ça va quand je dis au premier ministre
au nom de fo il ya quelques semaines au
début du débat
quand ça monte suspendez votre projet de
loi il dit un report c'est une
suspension junon c'est pas la même chose
un report vous décalée de 15 jours une
suspension vous mettez pas de calendrier
n'est pas pour le statu quo il faut que
les choses évoluent mais au moins qu'on
discute du de tous qu'on mette tout sur
la table
il ya un refus à partir de là ce qu'on
veut c'est effectivement on se mobilise
pour retirer le projet de loi à leur
mobilisation justement c'est jeudi
ouais vous pensez que vous serez combien
dans la rue on rappelle mme stead entre
250000 et 500000 oui seul entre la
police et les manifestants les
organisateurs je ne sais pas combien on
sera plus nombreux
oui je pense qu'on sera plus nombreux -
enfin je mesure ça en tous les cas ce ce
qui me remonte au sein de force ouvrière
des départements des entreprises etc
il ya parfois des entreprises qui se
mobilisent pas et veulent beaucoup et
qui là sont prêtes à se mobiliser il ya
des arrêts de travail qui sont déposées
donc je pense qu'on sera nombreux
ouvriers
si on est nombreux et dans tous les cas
de figure il y aura une suite et du côté
des jeunes on a vu que le mouvement
étudiant la semaine dernière c'était un
peu essoufflée est ce que la wii mais
c'est logique si vous voulez on
s'attendait à ce qu'il ya un petit
essoufflement fin du côté des étudiants
c'est pas nous qui décidons pour les
étudiants
toutes les semaines ça rythme ça rythme
un mouvement mais vous verrez je pense
que le 31 ils seront nombreux dans la
rue c'est du cynisme de faire appel à la
jeunesse selon emmanuel macron puisque
vous ne les protège et sa mise à l'écart
mais il est drôlement verdino ah oui et
il a dit vous avez vu à cannes il ya
quelques semaines on ne protège pas les
jeunes au travail avec ce genre de
manifestation on les protège du travail
ou énorme enfin ça c'est les formules
écouter emmanuel macron ca libéral donc
lui il croyait la loi va pas assez loin
pour lui donc si il croit que je sais
les jeunes de l'unef ou les études des
lycéens c'est ils ont des consignes
qu'ils reçoivent de je ne sais qui mike
plant c'est tout qui regardent la vie
c'est simplement il se décide tout seul
l'europe a besoin de nous et puisqu'on
parle de d'emmanuel macron est-ce que
vous sa grande théorie à lhuis de dire
finalement en france on défend les gens
ce qu'ils appellent les insiders les
gens qu'ils sont protégés qui ont un cdi
etc
face à eauze outsider et les précaires
les chômeurs extrait on a construit un
système qui favorise les gens qui sont à
l'intérieur est dehors il fait froid et
finalement il ya une injustice dans ce
système un truc de vieux ça fait
longtemps qu'on parle de ça les insiders
et l'avons fait readers bah oui attendez
il ya quel est le problème pourquoi il
ya autant de contrats de travail en
france
pourquoi il ya autant de formules de
contrat à durée déterminée qui les a
demandé sur les syndicats qui est des
cdd de remplacement inéluctable ça c'est
tout à fait mais la multiplication y
compris des cdd courts c'est les
employeurs comme demander ça alors que
c'est quoi la solution c'est de
fragiliser le cdi pour en disant on aura
moins de cdd c'est la même logique que
ceux qui disent pour pouvoir embaucher
de mapfre déjà licencié aujourd'hui moi
je conteste cette logique là d'abord
elle a aucune preuve
personne ne nous a sorti une étude
fiable disant voilà ce type de solution
voilà sacré et ça crée des emplois même
l' ocde qui a fait une étude approfondie
constate qu'on peut pas faire un lien
entre plus de flexibilité et de
précarité ce sont les patrons qu'il
défendra prod enclin à embaucher si on
lui oui les mairies dont est un million
et puis ces thérapies on sait ce que ça
donne bon mais moi j'étais aujourd'hui
et ça je comprends le chef d'entreprise
tpe pme qui se posent des questions etc
mais on peut répondre à ça d'une autre
manière que de dire en vain flexibiliser
les contrats de travail on peut encore
améliorer les procédures de conciliation
je rappelle que les ruptures de contrats
travail en a quand même pas mal y
compris des cdi cas les ruptures
conventionnelles et puis que les
oreillons personnes fassent leur boulot
quels conseils des entreprises comme
nous on conseille les seules arrivées
alors vous préférez peut-être la
position de françois rebsamen qui a
exprimé ce matin des réserves sur le
texte ont ils
il a même dit que s'il était encore rue
de grenelle il n'aurait pas accepté de
porter le texte est ce que vous vous
réjouissez de ce soutien soirée soutien
timide
c'est un soutien c'est un soutien timide
c'est pas très gentil vis-à-vis de son
successeur quand il dit ça mais ça et
qu'ils se débrouillent avec elle précisé
qu'il n'attend pas de miracle de la loi
oui non mais oui mais qui peut prétendre
aujourd'hui que cette loi va créer des
emplois moi je pense qu'elle vende vent
détruire des emplois dans un premier
temps cette loi je pense qu'elle va plus
en détruire qu'autre chose donc c'est
pas que quelques points ici ou là qu'il
faut corriger
c'est la philosophie générale de la loi
qu'il faut remettre en cause quand la
ministre parle de négociations enfin
privilégier l'entreprise c'est là où la
pression est la plus forte sur les
salariés chaque fois qu'il y aura une
entreprise que rennes difficulté qu'est
ce qu'ils vont dire à main vous acceptez
de talent est payée de 30 39 heures
payées 35 ou de baisser vos salaires etc
vous n'êtes pas d'accord vous êtes
licencié même plus pour motif économique
pour motif personnel
voilà ce qu'il ya dans cette loi ce que
nous avions obtenu du parlement 2013 que
ce soit toujours un licenciement
économique ça saute dans le projet le
temps mais toutes ces mesures de
souplesse est ce que répète myriam et le
cow boy sur le ferons avec l'accord des
syndicats l'accord des syndicats sous
pression quand il en aura et puis après
quand si on n'arrive pas à voir 50% on
fait un référendum
c'est ça que ça veut dire 1 vous à vous
imaginer dans l'entreprise les deux
syndicats qui représentent 32% signé un
accord on leur donne huit jours pour
essayer de convaincre les non
signataires huit jours de bordel dans la
boîte et après s'ils n'ont pas trouvé
vous avez un l'organisation possible
d'un référendum
ça veut dire à nouveau conflit dans
l'entreprise entre les non-signataires
les signataires et les salariés en
termes de dialogue social etc c'est bien
foutu va pas un facteur de démocratie
syndicale le référendum on n'en voit
plus que c'est un pas puisque c'est un
facteur de démocratie politique au
parlement c'est pas un acte de confiance
envers les syndicats n'ont pas ça
c'est un élément de court circuitage
scène alors je vous propose d'écouter le
chef des coucous selon votre expression
il ya quelques instants ici leur berger
de la cfdt donc syndicats réformistes
qui a contesté au départ c'est comme ça
que les formateurs des formateurs et de
leur maison la cogestion ils veulent
toujours participé open dans l'argot
vous ne dit pas non à tout non je ne dis
pas non à tout mais réformiste c'est pas
la différence c'est que nous on veut pas
participer alain giguère réformiste et
qui avec eux qui avaient donc contesté
au départ la réforme
elle couvrait avant de se rallier au
texte marquera plaît et qu'il ya donc
des mots très durs vous concernant en
l'écoutent et je n'ai jamais eu ma carte
au parti socialiste contrairement à
d'autres leaders syndicaux et je ne
connaissais pas par exemple chez le
belge jean claude mailly par exemple et
je ne connaissais pas et je dis pas que
je le critique par l'iphone mais je ne
sais pas fait et je le dis je ne les
connaissais pas avant d'arriver parce
que mons ma seule boussole ma seule
ambition c'est d'être le porte parole
des salariés de leurs intérêts je ne
suis pas achetable je ne suis pas
acheter et j'ai dû me vend à personne
alors petite question jean claude mailly
est ce que vous êtes toujours aurais je
n'ai jamais caché
alors je suis ni acheter ni acheter non
plus parce que si j'ai été un soldat du
parti socialiste ce serait pas dans
cette position je prendrai la position
de laurent berger dans la loire 11
heures
non même pas je suis syndicaliste comme
mes prédécesseurs qui avaient cette
carte aussi que ce soit bergeron que ce
soit blondel voilà maintenant je ne m'en
mêle pas
c'est mon droit à titre individuel je ne
m'en cache pas parce que c'est pas
secret et ceci étant ça ne m'empêche pas
et comme disent certains au gouvernement
tu nous c'est toi qui nous emmerde le
plus bas oui c'est une preuve
d'indépendance et tous n'ont peut-être
pas tous mariés leurs bras mais vous
savez on n'a pas besoin d'avoir une
carte au parti socialiste pour être
d'accord avec le gouvernement regarde et
leurs bergers alors le gros show le gros
chantier en parallèle de cette loi c'est
les négociations sur l'unedic mais l'a
finalement on n'a pas trop avancé
puisque
on a surtout parlé ces dernières
semaines du statut des intermittents
il ya des propositions il ya un accord
qui se dessine entre le medef et la cfdt
et puis les propositions pour que l'état
paye une partie des économies qui devait
être fait
est ce que c'est un modèle que vous
approuvez ce que vous pourriez soutenir
cet accord non bon le on signera passé
de ce morceau d'accord que les choses
soient claires qu'il faille faire des
économies etc on est d'accord on est
prêt à discuter là dessus mais pas à la
hauteur de ce que veut le patronat et la
cfdt apparemment parce que si haut ça va
jusqu'à 185 millions sur deux ans + 185
millions sur les deux années qui suivent
alors que ces mêmes pendant la période
de l'accord ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que demain il ya plus d'un
an exclues tandis que ses équivalents
aux cdd 1 donc ça veut dire qu'on remet
en cause ses annexes 8 et 10
et en plus dans un régime paritaire
gérée conjointement patronat syndicats
c'est nous qui appelons l'état à la
rescousse et demain on va demander à
l'état qui siège aussi à l'unedic donc
s'y remettre en cause le paritarisme
alors si c'est ça on ne signera pas un
on ne signera pas cet accord à 185
millions on était prêt à avancer mais
nous on veut pas demandé de l'argent
l'état je rappelle que l'état doit
mettre 100 millions dans un fonds non
pas pour le chômage mais pour l'emploi
c'est qui est un élément important
alors maintenant ces choses sont claires
s'il y en a qui veulent signer ce truc
bas ils signeront ce truc et puis on
verra ce que ça donne derrière les
économies et vous-même en fait c'est ça
que vous rient mais dans tous les cas de
figure il ya des économies à faire et on
est prêt à regarder les choses
abon est prêt à regarder autour de 100
millions d'économies mais pas où tu mets
sur deux ans un mets pas ça se discute
ça ça on est prêt à discuter là dessus
on l'a dit clairement on a même fait des
propositions en la matière mais la 185
me enfin attendez on a un medef qui se
radicalise qui fait qui veut faire
pression y compris sur le gouvernement
par rapport à la loi par rapport aux
c'est son problème
bon que des syndicats suivre c'est leur
problème mais si longtemps nous si c'est
ça et puis derrière on va arriver dans
le dur des négociations l'unedic c'est à
dire le total de tous les salariés du
privé
est ce qu'il ya une proposition qui est
de
d'intro d'instaurer la dégressivité des
allocations chômage ont la cgpme côté
patronat propose ça le medef ne parle
pas pour le montrent les premiers en
avoir parlé c'est le gouvernement je
vous rappelle un cadre qu'a dressé cette
piste non d'abord parce qu'on a un peu
de mémoire ça a été fait jean marie le
guen qui était à votre place n'est pas
muni du travail jean marie lemaire
d'érosion d'ailleurs allumé la mèche en
tous les cas oui mais il fait que ça
allumer des mèches ceci étant dans les
années 90 on avait utilisé ce système ça
n'a pas marché on l'a arrêté
bon par contre il ya des choses à faire
nous on va re proposer un système qu'on
appelle de bonus malus pour c'est pas
simplement une question financière c'est
pour changer le comportement des
employeurs pour limiter ça veut dire sur
par rapport à l'utilisation de l'intérim
et des cdd
ainsi une entreprise abusent des cdd par
rapport à une moyenne qu'on peut
calculer branche par branche
elle paye plus cher de cotisation
d'assurance assauts de la taxe oui c'est
une surcotisation un ici elle se
comporte mieux elle a un bonus elle paye
moins 1 mais il faut changer le
comportement des entreprises le problème
c'est que beaucoup d'entreprises ont
trop facilement recours à des cdd très
très court de 15 jours un mois
c'est ça qu'il faut dissuader raccourcir
la durée d'indemnisation des plus de 50
ans ça c'est aussi une des pistes est ce
que vous avez une partie des plus de 50
ans de la route
quand vous regardez l'évolution la
statistique du chômage le seule
catégorie pour laquelle ça n'a jamais
baissé c'est ce qu'on appelle les
seniors 1 donc ça continue à monter mois
après mois et le chômage de longue durée
augmente et de plus en plus comme loge
départ à la retraite recule vous avez de
plus en plus de seniors qui ont épuisé
leurs droits à l'assurance chômage et
qui basculent aux minima sociaux dont
myspace hulu rsa si on recule l'âge ça
veut dire qu'on va accélérer sa je pense
pas que dans une situation si millions
en gros de demandeurs d'emploi puissent
une part croissante de deux seniors on
peut jouer à ça mais on dit que c'est un
frein justement au retour au travail des
seniors de plus de 50 ans a pris parce
qu'il sait sont des feignants et plus de
50 ans donc ils cherchent pas du boulot
il préfère être indemnisé c'est ça on
connaît c'est eux quand ils avaient
autant de chômeurs que ça ça ne tient
pas serait de ce type de raisonnement
ainsi c'est pas tout de former les gens
il faut les former faut améliorer de
chômage mais à la fin il faut des
emplois qui se créent
parce qu'une formation son emploi ça
sert pas à ça sert pas à grand chose
des secteurs où ça marche y compris avec
des cdi prenez des secteurs artisanaux
comme la boucherie par exemple ils
forment en reconversion y compris des
gens qu'une quarantaine d'années qui
veut se reconvertir en âne en alternance
90% un cdi à la sortie on voit que c'est
dur de parvenir à un accord ou penser
que c'est possible avant l'été
c'est possible oui c'est toujours
possible si on n'a pas un patronat
jusqu'au boutisme des organisations
syndicales qui accepte tout si on peut
avoir quelque chose de correct oui moi
j'espère qu'on va trouver quelque chose
de correct et comme toujours quand on
est d'accord on signe quand on n'est pas
d'accord on signe pas ça on ne sait pas
avant est ce que vous espérez mobilisés
donc on l'a entendu jeudi dans la rue
est ce que vous espérez en quelque sorte
un amalgame et les oppositions avec les
intermittents du spectacle vous avez
pris la défense il ya on en a on n'en
est pas là pour le moment mais pas abba
attendez moi c'est pas écouté c'est pas
moi qui ai fixé la loi elle comme riz le
calendrier c'est la négociation
assurance chômage
elle devait démarrer là c'est pas nous
qui avons demande donc ces opérations
vont se relever on verra écoutez moi
j'en sais rien pour le moment on va voir
ce que ça va donner que ça vous fait
rien quand on a compris
non mais là pour le moment maintenant
c'est aux professionnels du secteur chez
les intermittents un patronat et
syndicats de se prononcer à voir ce
qu'ils vont dire également peut-être
juste sur la suite du mouvement est ce
qu il yad autres dates qui sont déjà à
riad et la déchirure elles sont pas
arrêtés rires oui oh bah oui on va pas
attendre le mois de mai ça c'est évident
je vous rappelle que ses débuts en
commission début avril à l'assemblée
début mai donc la pression ou à la
maintenir voilà donc on verra si
effectivement il ya plus de monde jeudi
que la dernière fois dans les rues c'est
ce que vous avez annoncé
oui je sais qu'il y aura plus de monde
je suis optimiste vous êtes optimiste
une question sur la reconnaissance du
fait religieux oui dans les entreprises
nouvellement cette reconnaissance ne
figurera pas dans la loi elles
compriment et va servir sans doute
d'inspiration à la refonte du code du
travail est ce que ça vous inquiète
oui mais bien entendu on a en a eu un ou
deux problèmes notamment 1
a la ratp bon mes camarades ont refusé
certains certaine adhésion parce qu'elle
répondait à une logique communautarisme
ceci étant nous mêmes positions depuis
toujours qui est claire là dessus dans
l'entreprise comme dans l'administration
l'entreprise ou l'administration ce
n'est ni un lieu d'expression politique
ni un lieu d'expression religieuse
un concert dans la religion ça s'appelle
la laïcité bakker mais y compris dans
les entreprises qui sont des lieux
privés contrairement aux animations
publiques pour nous lance pour vous il
ya pas de pressions politiques sont pas
de diminuer en lieu d'expression
religieuse très sérieux d'expression
économique social dehors pas autre chose
merci encore marc ruelle michaël szames
et ça arrive maintenant pour la
troisième partie de preuve par trois
mais quelle qui va se vous soumettre
cette affirmation donc de manuel valls
le retour de la droite serait synonyme
de rupture de notre modèle social
en 2017 vous allez pouvoir nous dire si
vous partagez cette opinion en tous les
cas cette idée de rupture renvoie bien
sûr à nicolas sarkozy qui a livré ce
commentaire il y a quelques jours sur la
démocratie sociale
moi je suis très heureux que les
centrales syndicales se soit bien
comportée en 1945
enfin nous sommes en 2016 c'est pas
parce qu'on s'est bien comportée en 1945
qu'on est réputé représentatif en 2016
voter la réforme des retraites pourquoi
on a réussi la réforme des retraites
avec eric woerth
pour une raison simple c'est qu'aucun
syndicat n'a signé avec nous pour ça
c'est parfaitement donc on n'a pas eu à
faire de compromis
donc on a pas on n'a pas dû payer entre
guillemets pour avoir la réforme et
c'est pour ça que la réforme rapporte
d'1 2 milliard par an donc il faut bien
changer le paradigme de la démocratie
sociale sinon on n'en peut plus et c'est
ça qui bloque
bonsoir mais qu'elle amène oublie
complètement gênait un peu mais oui
bonsoir excuse non je peux je réagis
deux choses d'une part on n'a pas à
signer parce que c'est une loi est donc
une loi ça se signent pas ça se négocie
pas ça se concertent premiers éléments
deuxième élément il oubliait que sous sa
responsabilité près dans la république
il ya une loi sur la représentativité
syndicale donc folie rafraîchir donc les
hostilités sont ouvertes en vue de 2017
si nicolas sarkozy revient au oui/non m
c'est moi je ne suis pas j'ai pas les
attendait à vous écouter
oui non mais là je réagis est ce que
jean bien sûr j'ai pas lu son bouquin
etc vous savez on en n'est pas là pour
le moment 1 et moi de nous on adore
parler j'avais des propositions des
fonctionnaires on n'a jamais donné de
consigne de vote
et on ne donnera jamais de consigne de
vote ça c'est parce qu'ils vivent là
encore a lancé le chef de l'état il l'a
dit lors de soi qu'ils me fassent
connaître la fondation de ma porte que
l'on doive que françois hier à donner
une consigne de vote il y aura bien du
mal à trouver alors jean claude mailly
quand vous entendez le premier ministre
manuel valls dire si la droite et
tellure 2017 c'est la rupture du modèle
social tel qu'on le connaît aujourd'hui
c'est le cas selon vous pas il a déjà
pris un coup dans le nez le modèle
social donc il a été touché l'os hilal
modèles ba oui les temps il elle
étendait là quand on regarde y compris
que tenait avec ce projet de loi quand
je disais tout à l'heure que pour moi je
les dis au premier ministre pour moi
c'est une rupture
ce projet de loi chants pas de rupture
politique je parle d'une rupture dans la
manière dont les négociations sont
menées dans notre pays
c'est une rupture y compris avec une
conception de la république sociale
tueur du modèle social ah bah oui bien
sûr s'ils sont aussi parce que je vous
rappelle que s nous a répondu manuel
valls que danser dès samedi avec la
droite ce serait pire il vous a dit la
même chose
non nous produisons ben c'est ce qu'ils
disent danser mais avant il me l'a pas
dit mais bon écoutez va certes mais moi
je vais faire un malheur mais on n'en
est pas là j'ai accepté ça veut dire
quoi accepter ce qu'on vous dit pas ce
que ce sera pire demain
oui mais moi je vis dans l'instant
présent je vis dans l'instant présent
dans l'instant présent on a un projet de
loi qu'on compte qu'on conteste dont on
demande le retrait parce qu'il remet en
cause le modèle social si la france ne
se réforme pas dit il à les condamner
une rupture conservatrices donc vous
n'acceptez pas de bouger donc vous êtes
avec les conservateurs c'est un peu ça
sur pousse le cerveau est on pousse un
peu ouais c'est un peu ça enfin web
enfin c'est un peu simplet quand même
excusez moi c'est pas par rapport aux
coûts passés à feu voilà vous me
soutenez où ce sera pire aux vins rouges
ou crève à l'oeil
sinon demain ou de risquer d'en perdre
deux mais même un oeil je le gardais
mois est ce que vous craignez retour de
la droite mais peu je me sens je ne suis
pas je me situe pas là dedans
franchement je me situe pas là dedans
syndicalisme on a nos positions on a nos
revendications on a nos analyses
quand même regardé par exemple les
programmes des différents candidats aux
primaires pas encore à granby ion et
propose un ensemble
franchement je fonce environ 500000
fonderie nicolas sarkozy 300 me lécher
la course à l'échalote d'accord oui bah
oui mais attendez missane
ça n'a aucun sens pardonnez moi qui nous
disent où ils veulent où ils veulent les
retirer voilà quand vous dites quand on
roule vers lui par exemple il dit
les fonctionnaires territoriaux on les
arrête les supprime voilà et puis alors
comment on fait que la régionalisation
comment on fait avec les transferts de
compétences c'est donc le retour de la
droite ça serait la rupture du modèle
c'est ça mais nous séparer mais c'est
ils sont enfin au delà d'eux c'est une
course à l'échalote
il en rajoute les uns et les autres on
met tous tous il en rajoute une quand
même coton neergaard la ligne économique
général je parvienne la ligne économique
générale tenez pas l'impact budgétaire
européen il a été négocié par sarkozy il
appliqué par hollande
bon ça quand même ça la réalité des
choses donc il peut y avoir des
variations etc
mais la ligne c'est la même après ils
peuvent ils peuvent en rajouter les uns
et les autres comme mais moi je
franchement je n'ai pas lu les
programmes des uns et des autres je
participe pas aux primaires manuel valls
dans les airs temps l'instant manuel
valls y va un petit peu plus loin et dix
réformes et ne pas réformer ou le statu
quo c'est choisir la condamnation à la
rupture vous êtes à résigner à lons
contraire j'ai tout contrairement à
résigner mois assuré dans ses duels face
à la chose que verger ils disent tous la
même chose si on réforme pas c'est le
statu quo mais ils ont vu ça où il vit
dans un monde binaire cwi blanc non il
faut changer le code du travail
peut-être parce qu'il faut oui mais
c'est quoi une réforme c'est remettre en
cause des droits
regardez l'histoire du référendum des
50% imaginez un seul instant que
n'importe quel accord n'importe quel
niveau si c'est pour améliorer le droit
on n'a pas besoin et 50% tout le monde
signe si on introduit c'est ce truc là
c'est pour remettre en cause des droits
sinon ça n'est pas ça n'est pas utile
alors la réforme c'est pas tout casser
la réforme c'est un symbole c'est un bon
mot la réforme mais depuis des années on
est en train de le détourner de le
remettre en cause
oui pour des réformes on est partisan
des réformistes on est partisan de la
réforme mais pas pour tout remettre en
cause à chaque fois donc ça peut pas
être le statu quo d'abord ça bouge tout
le temps y compris le code du travail il
bouge tout le temps ce serait même
peut-être pas si mal que ça qu'à un
moment donné que ce soit en matière de
travail que ce soit en matière de
fiscalité
on est un peu plus de stabilité dans le
pays alors vous vous êtes pour des
réformes vous le dit
même sans regarder le programme des
différents candidats aux primaires de la
droite il y a eu une idée un qui est
partagée par le plus grand nombre c'est
de se passer de la négociation sociale
en cas d'alternance en 2017 puisque tous
proposent des mesures les grandes
réformes par des ordonnances ou même des
référendums est-ce que cela ça vous
inquiète comme s'indigne rim et bien sûr
alors c'est pas c'est un signe de
démocratie ça c'est comme les 49 3
franchement c'est pas un signe de
démocratie
si l'on voulait bon peut à titre
personnel je peux penser que c'est pas
syndicales que la constitution fort elle
a révisé d'une manière ou d'une autre
banc mais ceci étant de ou pas ou de
faire des référendums ou de faire du
49-3 procéder par ordonnance c'est des
actes d'autorité c'est pas un aigle
démocratie ne dialoguent saxo d'autorité
vous avez dit manuel valls il a un petit
peu changé ces derniers temps en tout
cas c'est ce qu'on nous dit il fait de
la pédagogie peut-être que vous avez pu
constater aussi le renouveau réunions
bilatérales
c'est visiblement les vertus de la loi
travail vous nous l'avez changé
moi j'aimerais bien mais c'est ça les
mots etc
c'est moi ce qui m'importe c'est pas ce
pas les mots c'est pas le comportement
s'est contenu des textes que ce quel que
soit le premier ministre quel que soit
le président c'est sur le contenu qu'on
travaille et l'a pas fait preuve de
pédagogie avec vous sur cette
négociation de loi avec vous non mais
avec d'autres peut-être on a évoqué les
sensations même s'ils voulaient
contester c'est comme quoi ils reculent
comment vous aimeriez le voir changer
donc j'aimerais que lui qui se dit et je
crois sincère qui se dit républicain qui
parle souvent de la république
j'aimerais bien que sur le terrain
social ils comprennent que la république
ça existe aussi
vous parliez tout à l'heure de manuel
macron le libéral vous rappelle qu'on se
rencontre sur l'agriculture ouais mais
il est écrit avec le avec le libéral
mais moi je fais toujours la part des
choses il ya deux mots essentiels donc
comportements des uns et des autres le
respect et la confiance c'est vrai on va
dire qu'on est d'accord quand on est en
désaccord ça c'est la démocratie
mais c'est pas une raison je parie taper
dessus quand le bonhomme en plus
humainement il est sympathique on peut
discuter même quand on est en désaccord
de fond et ça nous arrive régulièrement
mais il respecte confiante à 11 que je
ne tolère pas c'est le manque de respect
ou le manque de confiance
y compris à mon égard c'est le cas par
exemple de
la cfdt si j'ai bien compris parce que
depuis tout à l'heure qu'est ce que vous
tapez serait con ils attaquent moi je
réponds confiance est cassé ah oui
depuis les retraites complémentaires il
est cassé moi j'aime pas qu'on me
raconte des histoires c'est fini avec un
problème au maire charles x oui et avec
la cgt en revanche contre leurs infos
dans ce programme ou au temps des noms
on va pas se pacser pas quand je dis pas
que c'est les deux organisations c'est
pas possible d'ailleurs l'histoire le
l'histoire ne permet pas on est très
différents les uns des autres là on est
dans une unité d'action
ça pourrait être avec d'autres il ya
d'autres organisations 1 mais à un
moment donné c'est pareil respect
confiance maintenant le vrai aussi
critiqué tout à l'heure jean marie le
guen pour toutes les mèches qu'ils
allumaient alors il ya des secrétaires
d'état aux relations avec le parlement a
dit récemment qu'il y avait trop de
syndicats en france est ce que c'est un
avis que vous partagez vos également
écouter une musique raï qu'on avait fait
une loi sur la représentativité pour
auxerre ce qu'ils avaient accepté pour
qui on est moins pas pour le moment
c'est parra réussit on a toujours autant
m'attendais moi j'ai toujours dit c'est
les salariés qui décident de leur
organisation
maintenant c'est pas la peine d'en faire
une dizaine quoi il y en aurait moins ce
serait peut-être pas plus mal année
c'est pas une voie qui change sa sont
les salariés bien sûr le climat y est ce
que vous comprenez ceux qui ont voté
françois hollande en 2012 et qui disent
maintenant c'est fini je me détourne et
j'arrête 2017 ou ailleurs il est arrivé
avec le bourget on est là récupéré cic
je vais vous partagez cet avis mouais je
peux réussir le pire en plus sain entre
nous et le pack de responsabilité cpd si
vous faites partie des déçus a même
enchaîné vous savez depuis j'ai voté moi
non je ne sais pas mais là je vais pas
vous avez en poche quand même on peut se
vend des gens savaient rien alors bien
sûr on sait rien on savait rien non mais
vous ne demandez pas ce que voulez vous
n'allez pas dire non je le dirai pas et
en plus c'est pas parce qu'on a une
carte que voilà ça n'a rien à voir pas
obligatoirement en tous les cas c'est
quand même étrange de voir des fois
c'est un titre personnel c'est mon
problème c'est pas mais à titre syndical
je défends et je pratique la dépendance
syndicales tous les jours et je vous
assure que parfois c'est pas simple et
que peut être que l'année preuve vous
imaginez tenez un résultat de
présidentielle avec au deuxième tour un
candidat de droite ou de gauche j'en
sais rien quelle que soit l'étiquette et
le front national est alors présenté là
on est plus en 2002 je rappelle qu'en
2010 on n'avait pas donné de consigne de
vote mais c'est pas moi qui était
secrétaire général
et j'aime appuyer cette position parce
que vous donnerez pas en 2017 aucune en
aucune façon on dira ce qu'on a à dire
sur les positions et c'est parce que je
vous rappelle que ça fait trois ans
trois ans que j'explique régulièrement
et je les dis au président de la
république je l'aï dit à plusieurs
reprises que la logique d'austérité ou
de rigueur d'appel ça comme on veut
c'est suicidaire socialement premier en
cause des droits économiquement ça
plombe la croissance et démocratiquement
vous vous laisserez faire et que j'ai su
que je laisse faire
si moi je me bats 1 et quand ce que j'ai
dit au président de la république en
cours à la conférence sociale que l'une
des raisons du monte en france comme
ailleurs c'est quand je discute avec mes
collègues européens
vous avez ça dans les pays nordiques
vous avez ça en belgique vous avez vu ce
qui s'est passé ce week-end en belgique
mais quand je
l'essentiel pour nous des raisons c'est
quoi c'est une situation économique et
sociale en france comme ailleurs
donc si l'on en est tous d'accord on
n'est pas tous d'accord qui dopent quand
je dis ça mais voilà il me répond non
c'est essentiel c'est un problème
identitaire
vous voyez qu'on n'a pas la même analyse
d'accord mais donc si effectivement il
ya un duel entre le front national et un
candidat de gauche ou de droite parce
que ne prendrait pas position en 2010 à
20h
nous dirons ce que nous avons à
disposition pas donne pas de consigne de
vote formel comme on l'a fait en 2002 on
vous assure vous savez être indépendant
c'est pas simplement un coup de temps en
temps pour faire plaisir l'indépendance
syndicale est pas donné de consigne de
vote
c'est aussi dans les moments où c'est
pas s'arrêter là vous n'arrêtez pas de
parler de la des valeurs de la
république depuis louis xvi à propos de
la loi travailler vos nous dit qu'en cas
de duel entre le français demeurer un
parti dit républicain lorrain devoir
dire et rien dire sur les positions
ferment la vision de nous rappeler de
consigne de vote formel non d'abord quel
titre un syndicat donne une consigne de
vote
les gens ils font ce qu'ils veulent dans
l'isoloir je verrai si on en arrivait là
qu à aba dans un autre sens
organisations demandent jamais où ils
font ce qu'ils veulent pendant leur voix
de politique
ben oui ces citoyens qui votent c'est
pas le top 14 et la jeunesse omj ipsos
après les élections je voudrais savoir
le chiffre aujourd'hui il y avait
énormément de personnes qui sont
syndiqués chez fo dont le dit ce proche
qui se disent proches ça fêter ça ne
veut pas dire qu'ils sont adhérents qui
avaient voté pour le front national que
vous acceptez ça dans votre syndicat
bakhit a dit justin c'est d'abord ce
sont pas obligatoirement des adhérents
c'est des gens qui se disent proches du
sondage sortie des urnes
il y en a dans les autres organisations
aussi dans tout les organisera
valora à peu près un tiers oui je veux
de mémoire c'était effectivement dans
ces eaux là
un bémol près qu'ils le disent ils le
disent pas et aujourd'hui vous avez vous
savez mes chances et rien je ne fais pas
de statistiques là dessus et pas de
statistiques dont la renommée acteurs
vous savez il faut s'il en est sont très
démocratique
ça veut dire que si un adhérent dans une
réunion disait moi je m'exprime au titre
de tel ou tel parti quel qu'il soit il
finit pas sa phrase
on n'est pas là pour ça donc on n'a pas
ce type de débat dans l'organisation on
est sur les positions et les
revendications défend les valeurs
républicaines
mais à un moment donné il faut se poser
la question c'est bien gentil tout ça
mais ça fait casser le thermomètre
ce qui m'inquiète c'est pas dans mon
organisation ça ça m'inquiète pas parce
qu'on n'a pas ce type de problème
ce qui m'inquiète c'est lé réseau qui se
développe c'est quoi les radiateurs
réseau dans les chambres de commerce
dans les chambres d'agriculture dans la
haute fonction publique
voilà il ya toute la france et au
compromis oui bien sûr
grâce à qu'ils aimaient ça c'est lui
mais l'a révélé lors urgent qu'ils se
développent proches etc
quelle est la leur mais pourquoi on en
arrive là si on ne veut pas comprendre
que c'est à cause en france comme en
europe apace que salée que les deux
seuls pays où si vous n'avez pas ce type
de problème
c'est quoi l'espagne et le portugal
pourquoi si à 40 ans c'étaient des
dictatures et que ça reste dans la tête
des espagnols et des portugais
mais vous allez dans les pays bas vous
discuté au danemark vous discutez qu'il
suédois vous avez ce type de problèmes
partout donc c'est bien la situation
économique et sociale qui crée ça ne pas
le reconnaître ne pas bouger
c'est un côté pyromanes comment est ce
que vous pouvez témoigner effectivement
de l'entrisme du front national dans
dans tous les endroits que vous avez
évoqué vous avez assez des témoignages
qu'on a cédé témoignages qu'on a des
organisations mais vous avez y compris
des employeurs qui s'affiche à la télé
voulait pas vu ça moi j'ai vu ça cet été
bon voilà qui se cache pas on vous fait
entrer deux c'est que ces souterrains
qu'on ne le voit pas forcément là sera
pas obligatoirement oui il existe les ai
pas épargné mais j'en sais rien parce
que je fais pas mais quand j j'en sais
rien je ne fais pas de statistiques et
personne va venir on a eu deux trois cas
qui sont sortis mais personne va venir
en disant moi je suis adhérent ps moi je
suis jade et rend il ya moi qui dis ça
parce que jusqu'à terre général j'ai pas
la peine de de cacher les choses mais
les gens ne viennent pas à fo ou ne
s'exprime pas il faut au titre d'un
parti politique quel qu'il soit il ya
une bonne partie qui sont nulle part un
chiffre peut-être chevance 39% des
fonctionnaires et ça c'est une
un sondage cevipof qui a été réalisé des
fonctionnaires de catégorie c ontre est
clair se tournent désormais vers le
front national
est-ce que ça c'est quelque chose qui
est nouveau est ce que c'est quelque
chose là j'ai par contre c'est ce que ça
vous inquiète est-ce que c'est quelqu'un
est nouveau quand vous avez un parti qui
fait les résultats qu'il fait prenez les
dernières élections régionales
bah oui ça signifie moi je prends ma
région d'origine que le arrondi pull
nord pas de calais maintenant les hôtes
france bah oui vous aviez la fois des
pas l'électorat socialiste
les fonctionnaires et ouvriers qui
viennent de là donc ce sont les déçus
bah oui parce qu'il ne voit pas parce
que quand vous avez d'une politique des
politiques menées les gens ils
raisonnent quoi il vous parle pas dans
les entreprises la déchéance de
nationalité
pas de ça dont il vous parle aujourd'hui
et vous parle de vos parle de quoi ils
vous parlent de leur emploi ils vous
parlent de leur salaire de leur pouvoir
d'achat des difficultés à faire les fins
de mois que la situation que ça mais
vous la réponse est donc le front
national c'est que j'en sais rien et ne
parle pas il me parle pas de ça y voilà
nos problèmes cela aujourd'hui
est ce qu'on constate c'est que ça ne
change pas et il ya du vote
peut-être d'adhésion pour certains mais
avait aussi du vote de contestation
maintenant la part des choses j'en sais
rien moi encore une petite question pour
conclure cette émission que vous avez
raconté
vous vous rendez vous avec manuel valls
vous en avez également avec le chef de
l'état
comment est ce que vous les percevez
l'un et l'autre dans leur approche du
fait social
je laisse entrer ils le disent pas mais
on laisse entrer déjà préoccupés par
l'année prochaine c'est à dire
l'élection présidentielle j'ai
l'impression que c'est ce qui guide
beaucoup de choses bien sûr oui vous
avez parlé des gestes en direction des
fonctionnaires notamment
oui mais d'une manière générale c'est
comment comment gagner une
présidentielle est mal je le dis je le
dis je l ai déjà dit et je le redis
quand quelqu'un qui veut être président
qui veut à nouveau l'aide peut importe
c'est que pour gagner il faut qu'en face
de lui il est le front national moi
démocratiquement ça m'inquiète d'accord
et on sait que c'est le calcul a coûté
sa appareils non ça apparaît puisque
tout le monde dit à deuxième tour voilà
bah pour moi ça me pose problème at-il
de personnel de citoyens
comment est ce que vous voyez
l'évolution des méria mail comme rica
étaient qui reste très contestée dans la
défense de son texte emblématique de la
fin du quinquennat
je sais pas écouté
ouais c'est qu'elle ne connaissait pas
ses dossiers ça c'est pas de sa faute
elle était secrétaire d'état dans un
autre secteur elle débarque là on lui
colle quand jauzion l'elysée matignon
lui colle ce qui est présenté comme un
des projets les plus lourds au du
quinquennat je pense pas pour n'est
obligatoirement voulu lui rendre service
est-ce qu'il faut croire les échos d'un
magazine qui s'appelle le point que tout
le monde connaît on peut dire que vous
discutez souvent avec martine aubry
qu'est-ce que vous trafiqué avec martin
brian rien je la connais je en plus
c'est toujours intéressant de discuter
du travail même si on n'est pas toujours
d'accord avec lui bien sûr mais discuter
avec elle parce que je vous rappelle
qu'elle a été ministre du travail deux
fois qu'elle était drh qui a été
directeur général du travail donc au
moins elle elle connaît c'est au jeu là
maintenant on fait moi je ne fais que
magenta mollinger non non non je ne fais
pas de politique politicienne avec vous
ou le point du qu'on ne sait plus quoi
pour mettre en cause voile c'est pas mon
problème franchement c'est pas ça moi
mon problème aujourd'hui c'est la loi
dit elle comme riz ou la loi sur le
travail et c'est vrai que avec elle
martine aubry on a des points de
convergence sur l'analyse du texte
elle sait ce que c'est que la hiérarchie
des normes mari soit on vous l'avait été
à défiler jeudi aussi avec vous un bon
jour jusqu'à on suivra donc l'ampleur
des manifestations qui est affrété dans
quelques jours merci beaucoup je dis
mais qu'elle savait merci à tous bon
soir a très vite